pausing and tempo
pausing isn't just about slowing down
pausing allows you to connect with your
audience
it also allows your audience to process
what it is you're saying
in addition you can segment your ideas
so it's easier to understand
frequently we get the nerves going and
we also know our own information
and we start rattling it off so fast
that people really can't even understand
it
or they might be challenged to try and
get on our train
and before we know it they're not even
focused on the meaning of our message
they're just trying to keep up think of
this
important people are never rushed
take your time when you place pause
in between things it creates importance
around whatever it is that you just
paused on
we'll give an example of this coming up
keep in mind
when you're presenting the nerves are
going
ground your energy slow down if you are
speaking as if you have the biggest
mouthful of chunky peanut butter in your
mouth you're probably doing it
right